humans have explored almost every inch
of Earth's surface and with satellite
imagery we can even observe tough to
reach places daily but this outer shell
makes up just a fraction of Earth
dense hot guts are impossible to reach
directly and that's especially true for
Earth's inner core
about the size of the planet Pluto the
inner core is made up of solid iron and
helps power the magnetic field that
protects life on Earth from harmful
space radiation
but the inner core might not be as old
as Earth itself analysis of titano
magnetite a mineral that captures the
strength of the surrounding magnetic
fields when it crystallizes show that
around 565 million years ago Earth's
magnetic field was drastically weaker a
mere 10 of its current stream
over tens of millions of years the
magnetic dynamos strengthen to what we
see today likely from the formation of
Earth's inner core
the inner core is a fairly recent
discovery geologically speaking and
scientists have been probing its secrets
of various tools ever since
for centuries people thought the Earth
might be Hollow or burning raging
Inferno
but by the early 20th century
researchers have settled on the idea of
a layered planet made up of a thin crust
a thick viscous mantle and a molten
Center
these layers were detected using seismic
waves to x-ray Earth
after earthquakes or the explosion of
bombs two types of waves Ripple through
our planet first come pressure are p
waves followed by Shear or S waves
key waves can make their way through
liquids and solids but liquids stop s
waste from spreading
researchers in the 1900s detected a P
wave on the other side of Earth after
they bent and refracted through the
Earth's interior by contrast the S waves
never made it through
that led scientists to think that
Earth's core was entirely liquid however
this theory was challenged when Inga
Lehmann a Danish seismologist noticed a
P wave in an unexpected place
Lehman concluded that it had to have
bounced off of something dense something
solid and the idea of Earth's center was
born a solid inner core suspended in the
liquid outer core
more recently researchers have made
another Discovery routes were P waste
travel at greater speeds particularly
along Earth's north-south axis
changes in these Fast Lanes hint at the
existence of an innermost core nestled
inside the inner core
researchers estimate that it's roughly
600 kilometers in diameter and slightly
offset from the planet's Center
yet many questions still remain about
its composition and how it formed
seismic ways of a different type have
led researchers to believe that the
inner core might spin at a different
rate than Earth itself
nuclear tests which can be located more
precisely than earthquakes have helped
researchers understand the inner core's
rotation
in 1971 in 1974 the Soviet Union
detonated two atomic bombs underground
in the Arctic
by comparing the waves that bounced out
the inner core from these tests
researchers found that the inner core
rotated slightly faster than the planets
but analysis of two earlier bomb-induced
earthquakes in 1969 and 1971 this time
set off by the U.S military under Alaska
solution Islands showed a different
Trend the inner core rotated slower than
the planet in this time period
while a change in the rotation speed is
likely other researchers think the
differences in how these seismic waves
travel are due to the surface of the
inner core changing shapes
Beyond setting seismic waves researchers
are also attempting to recreate their
inner core's extreme temperature and
pressure inside the lab
tests range from using Shockwave
experiments depressing and heating iron
between Diamond anvils
these experiments hope to get a glimpse
of the molecular structure of iron in
the inner core and one of these studies
suggests that the solid inner core might
actually be rather soft like a smoothie
with these new Tools in hand scientists
understanding of the inner core is
poised to explode bringing a revelatory
new look at the planet inside
[Music]